(cheering and applauding)
- [Kelly] You're right.
Like, all that crazy stuff I said,
and you look like Wonder Woman.
I'm like, what? You're,
you're like a goddess.
- Well, thank you, darling.
- [Kelly] Geez. I was like,
have you ever met Jane?
- We have never met in person.
- It is very nice to meet you.
- Yes.
- I like a tall chick.
- Yeah.
- How tall are you, dear?
- Well, short.
- Well, in the heels, like, 6'4.
- Oh, but you're a six-footer then?
- Yeah.
- I'm a six-footer too.
- There we go.
- High five on that, sis.
- Hey. Thank you.
- Yeah, yeah.
Okay, no, okay, no?
Just me?
5'3, guys.
Short people are cool too.
Well, take us back.
Did you always have a
passion for marketing?
Did you know this was your, like, path?
- No, I did not.
My parents are originally
from Ghana in West Africa.
So being first-generation American,
they wanted me to only
have one of three careers.
I could be a doctor, a
lawyer, or an engineer.
That was it.
- My God.
- You know what I mean?
Marketing was not-
- Bars high.
- Yeah, exactly.
So in college, I was pre-med.
Then I graduated with also a degree
in African-American History and English.
I mean, I was just doing all the things.
- [Kelly] That's cool.
That's what you're
supposed to do in college.
- I mean, you just explore, right?
- Yeah.
- But then I wanted to
take a little bit of time
before going to medical school to try
and, you know, figure
out what I wanted to do.
And I thought New York
City is big bad city.
I want to go, you know,
check it out and see what's happening.
- Yeah, so I went there and
discovered marketing. (laughs)
- [Kelly] How?
- Yeah.
- Like what?
- So here's the thing.
Now I'm a hustler.
- Okay.
- So I went to New York, no money.
I had one friend there.
I was sleeping on her couch,
and I would take jobs at temp agencies
to sort of make ends meet
to feed myself, right?
- Yeah.
- So literally on the corner
of 125th Street and Broadway,
there was a phone booth.
This is how long ago that was, you know.
- Phone booth.
- It wasn't, it wasn't a cell phone.
- Yeah,
- It was a phone booth.
And I would call into the temp
agency every single morning.
I would start calling them at 7:30,
call 'em every 15 minutes
until I got a job.
And, like, it took, like, six weeks
for me every single day
calling and then getting a job.
Finally, it was, like,
the golden day when I got a job
to be the receptionist at
Spike's advertising agency.
- Oh, wow.
- And so I get there,
and I'm only supposed
to answer the phones.
Now I see he's carrying around
something under his arm,
coming back and forth in the office.
It happened to be the
script for "Bamboozled".
And I asked him if I could read it,
being an African-American studies,
you know, literature person.
(Kelly laughs)
- I thought I could
perhaps give him some tips.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- I love it. Bold, though.
- Yeah, and naive.
- No.
- But it was, but it was perfect
because it's like, I think today,
I probably would've hesitated, right?
I would've been like:
"Oh, Spike, like, how can you
even give him any kind of tips at all?"
But at the time I was like:
"Oh, yes, I'm gonna do him a favor."
(claps)
- So I took, you know what I mean?
So I took the script, I marked it up,
gave it back to him.
(Kelly laughs)
- He looked at me like I would,
had lost my whole mind
and, no, but he looked at it and said:
"Okay, like, actually you
make some good points.
You should, you should
stay here for a while."
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
- That's what got my job.
- But that's what I find incredible.
But I think things I did too.
Whenever I was, like, 19,
I was, like, I moved to a
whole, across the state.
I lived here, didn't know anybody,
lived on a mattress, like-
- You know what I'm saying?
- and things to do when you're young,
I'm like: "I don't know
if I'd do that now."
- Exactly.
- It sounds like a real bad situation.
- Right, you know better now.
- Yeah, it sounds hard up.
- Yeah, it's so much better to do it then.
- Yeah. Did you do crazy stuff
like that when you were young?
- Yeah, like, flophouses with,
you know, a bunch of
friends putting on shows,
and we'd all lived together
and, you know, horrible little homes.
(laughing)
- Good times.
Well, so then 10 years ago,
everything shifted in your life.
So explain what happened.
- Yeah, well, 10 years ago,
I felt like I was really at the,
at a high, high in my career.
I was at PepsiCo.
I had worked with Beyoncé
on the deal with the NFL-
- Yeah.
- to put her on the "Super
Bowl Halftime Show".
I mean, we were like,
everything was popping.
- Yeah.
- And I had been married
for about 10 years,
and my husband, Peter,
was diagnosed with cancer.
- [Jane] Uh-huh.
- In May of 2013.
- [Kelly] Oh, wow.
- And our daughter was four.
You know, we were both, like,
doing very well in our career.
So you don't really think
anything bad is ever gonna happen.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And by December, he was dead.
- [Jane] Oh, God.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It was a very fast terminal cancer
that we were not prepared for.
I certainly wasn't.
And I really was unprepared
to be a single mom to
try and figure out life.
- Yeah.
- You know, by myself, all the things.
But I also have to be honest
that up until then, you know,
our marriage had been good,
but then we hit some rocky parts too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, like many marriages.
- You know, we were separated.
- I don't what you're speaking of.
- Right, well, yeah, exactly.
- Tell me.
(laughing)
- Yeah, you know, something we-
- It happens.
Yeah, you know, we were
separated for a few years.
- Yeah.
- And never got all
the way to the divorce.
And then when he was diagnosed
as terminal, we reconciled,
you know, to get through
the last bits of his life
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Bozoma] before he died.
- [Kelly] Also, I bet for
your daughter as well.
- Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
All the things. I wanted to
be able to have her share,
you know, the moment with us.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I got some really great advice
from a friend then who said,
you know, like, tell her the truth.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like, you know, even though she was four
because you don't wanna
do that, right, as a mom?
- Yeah, but, like, what
are you supposed to say?
- I mean, right, you
use, like, soft words.
But the advice I got, which, by the way,
I've used up until now, is
that you tell the truth.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, use the right words,
like, if you say, "Oh, Daddy's sick."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Well, every time,
like, somebody has a cold
or something else, and you
think: "Oh, they're sick."
She's gonna think something
terrible's about to happen.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So we use the right words, you know?
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- And when I had to tell
her that he was gone.
- I said exactly that.
- Ooh, that's hard.
- It is.
- After losing your husband,
you said you had real
conversations with your daughters.
- Yeah.
- So how did that shape you as a mama?
- Oh, my gosh.
- [Kelly] Those are hard conversations.
I've had, I think you all,
if you have kids at any,
my, mine are six and eight.
- Mm-hm.
- They are terrified of death right now.
- Right.
- They just, you know,
it's like people have died,
like, in their lives, and
they, they're terrified of it.
They think any, anytime
I leave on a plane,
anytime I do anything, they're like:
"Are you gonna come back?"
And I'm like, I, and I always, I'm honest.
I'm like: "I don't know, but
let's not wish the worst."
- Like, right?
Like, I don't know.
Yeah, I'm hoping I do.
Like, yeah.
- But I think in the back of our minds,
we all consider that, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We all consider things,
and maybe we don't wanna
talk about it exactly,
which is why I think it's so important
for us to be that much more-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- brave and courageous about it
'cause you don't know what's gonna happen.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I don't think it's
a morbid thing to do.
I should think it's very inspiring.
But the light for us has been
that Lael, who's my daughter.
She's now 13 and a half.
- It's such a beautiful name.
- Oh, thank you.
- Yeah, Lael, that's beautiful.
- Lael.
And I told her, I was like:
"Look, you're gonna become my partner
in this, okay, in raising you."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And she looked at me like: "Okay."
But I was like: "No, you're
gonna be my partner, and-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- you're gonna, you're gonna tell me
the things you need.
- Be honest.
- And I will tell you the things I need,
and we're gonna work it out together.
It has given her a voice in our house
and a voice in our, in our relationship.
And so I feel that it's a real benefit.
- It also teaches her how to have
relationships like that, to be honest.
- [Bozoma] Yes.
- What boundaries are created.
- Yeah, that's beautiful.
- And what you need.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- What you need.
- [Kelly] 'Cause sometimes people
aren't good at saying that.
They're coddled their whole life
and they aren't taught that.
And then all of a sudden
you're in college,
and you're, like, have these
unhealthy relationships,
and you're, they don't
know how to deal with it.
- Ooh, I need her to have a voice.
- [Jane] Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
- [Kelly] Absolutely, absolutely.
Well, you, I imagine your daughter's
definitely gonna have a voice.
I read your resume. I was like.
So you speak about being the
only black person in a room.
So have you seen that change at all or no?
- Mmm.
- Still needs progress.
- Mm.
- We need a lot of help.
- Yeah.
- There's a lot of help.
- I feel like we're in a time
when we talk a lot about
diversity and inclusion
and what we're gonna do to change things,
but the action. We need action.
- Seeing it actually implemented.
- Yes, we need action.
- We need more-
- Yeah.
- people of color in
boardrooms in the senior seats.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Not just in middle management.
So that's what I'm trying.
- [Kelly] I agree. I love that.
- [Bozoma] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Fabulous.
- I mean.
- But don't we make the boardrooms
just that much more fabulous?
I mean, look at it.
Like, it's just-
- I would go to that job.
I'm like, I'd wanna go to that meeting.
I'm like, what are we talking about?
So let's talk about the book.
- Yeah.
- So it's called "The Urgent Life".
And you open up about your life a lot,
which I think is incredibly brave
'cause it's hard to do that.
I don't know why I would do that.
So why did you wanna write it now?
Why did you feel like it was important?
- You know, there's, along my
career, as you could imagine,
people have told me to
write the marketing book.
You know that-
- Yeah.
- the "How To Be The
Marketing Executive" book.
- Yeah.
- But I have also found
that we have been taught
to be like two different people, right?
You have the personal side
and you have the professional side.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But that's actually not real.
That's not a true thing.
You're one person, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it's very, very difficult to show up
as your whole self in a job
if you're leaving some of it on the side.
You know, especially given
the fact that we've all
been through so much, you know,
everybody goes through loss.
Everybody goes through trauma.
Sometimes it's not maybe
what I have been through,
but you've been through something.
- Different challenges.
- And how to show for work like that.
- You know, are you supposed
to leave it outside?
How are you supposed to manage?
You know, and so part of the reason
I want to write the book right now
is because of what we've all,
as the whole global world,
been through in the last three years.
We've all suffered a lot, you know?
And how did you show up?
Not just at work, but, like,
in your community at school,
like in the different areas that we're in
and that perhaps we can be more honest
about what we're going through,
and therefore be able to
help each other some more.
- [Kelly] Because chances
are everybody else
in that room has got their
own different version-
- [Bozoma] Yes.
- of your private health.
- [Bozoma] Okay, exactly.
- [Kelly] Everybody's
got something going on.
I agree with that as well.
It's hard to compartmentalize.
That was actually a big thing for me.
Like, even just going through divorce
and, like, doing this job
and showing up and smiling
and, like, you know, you're
supposed to do something,
but it's, like, you're, I'm a human.
Like, you know, and, like, yeah,
I'm glad the show isn't live,
but it's a hard thing to ask people.
It's a hard thing to ask of
people without, like, saying,
well, no, you're allowed to be human-
- [Bozoma] Right.
- in a moment.
- [Kelly] Or in all the moments.